♪ ♪
>> WE REALLY NEED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF WHAT HAPPENED AT THE
FBI DURING COMEY YEARS.
>> JAMES COMEY SAID
ANDREW MCCABE STOOD TALL, WAS A
MODEL LEADER, NOW HE WANTS
IMMUNITY BECAUSE HE KNOWS HE IS
IN JEOPARDY WITH HIS CONDUCT
OVER THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> GIVING MR. McCABE COVER
THREE IMMUNITY WOULD BE A
MISTAKE.
>> I WOULD NOT GIVE HIM
IMMUNITY.
IF HE'S GOING TO PLEAD THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT, THEN HE SHOULD PLEAD
THE FIFTH.
>> IT'S UNHEARD OF FOR THE
NUMBER TWO PERSON IN THE FBI
SAYING, YOU WANT ME TO TESTIFY?
GIVE ME IMMUNITY.
>> Shannon: JONAH GOLDBERG,
SENIOR EDITOR AT NATIONAL
REVIEW.
SUSAN PAGE, WASHINGTON BUREAU
CHIEF AT USA TODAY "USA TODAY."
BYRON YORK, CHIEF POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT OF THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU.
THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT McCABE
AND IMMUNITY.
IT COMES AHEAD OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORTS.
ARE THEY CONNECTED?
>> I'M SURE THEY ARE CONNECTED.
HOW AND IN WHAT WAY REMAINS TO
BE SEEN.
I PERSONALLY AM VERY MUCH IN
FAVOR OF GETTING ALL THE
INFORMATION OUT HERE, WHATEVER
IT IS ABOUT COMEY, ALL OF IT.
I AM NOT SURE IT TRACKS TO SAY
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS, AS SENATOR CORNYN WAS
SAYING NO WAY SHOULD WE GIVE
THIS GUY IMMUNITY.
IF THAT'S THE WAY YOU GET THE
INFORMATION OUT OF HIM, THE
ARGUMENT THEY GO THE OTHER WAY.
IT SEEMS TO ME THERE IS AN
INTEREST IN THE OPTICS WHICH ARE
VERY BAD FOR McCABE, VERY BAD
FOR COMEY TO HAVE THE NUMBER TWO
GUY AT THE FBI PLEADING THE
FIFTH.
IF WE WANT TO GET THE
INFORMATION, I AM AGNOSTIC.
IF HE DESERVES TO GO TO JAIL, I
WANT HIM TO GO TO JAIL.
IF HE DOESN'T DESERVE IT, I
DON'T BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
NEED THE INFORMATION.
>> Shannon: U.S. ATTORNEY
LOOKING INTO WHAT WAS FOUND
BIASED SEPARATE REPORT, WHETHER
THERE WILL BE CRIMINAL
LIABILITY.
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY SAID
BEFORE EVEN BEGINNING TO
CONSIDER WHETHER TO INITIATE THE
PROCESS OF IMMUNITY, THE
COMMITTEE WOULD NEED TO KNOW A
LOT MORE ABOUT THE ANTICIPATED
SCOPE, NATURE AND EXTENT OF YOUR
TESTIMONY.
SUSAN, SOUNDS LIKE THEY ARE
LEAVING THE DOOR OPEN.
>> IT'S HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO TAKE THE FIFTH OR DEMAND
IMMUNITY IF THEY EXPECT HIM TO
TESTIFY.
BUT I AGREE THAT OPTICS IS THE
WORD OF THE DAY.
THE NUMBER TWO GUY AT THE FBI,
YOU DON'T EXPECT TO FIND HIM IN
THAT SITUATION BUT HE MUST BE
SURPRISED TO FIND HIMSELF IN
THIS SITUATION AFTER A CAREER IN
THE FBI.
TWO DAYS AWAY FROM RETIRING AND
HE GETS CAUGHT INTO THIS
CONTINUING CONTROVERSY OVER THE
CLINTON EMAILS AND OVER THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT HE LEAKED
INFORMATION TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" AND
THEN MISLED INVESTIGATORS ABOUT
IT.
IT'S GOT TO BE A SHOCKING THING
FOR HIM AND HIS FAMILY.
>> Shannon: WHAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND IN THE
REPORT WAS THERE WAS SOMETHING
LESS THAN FULLY HONEST AND A
NUMBER OF THESE.
HE AND COMEY WERE AT ODDS ABOUT
WHO WAS RIGHT AND WHAT
INFORMATION THEY SHARED.
COMEY PRAISED HIM PUBLICLY BUT
NOW SHOULD COMEY BE WORRIED
ABOUT McCABE MAY SAY THAT
COULD INFLUENCE OR HURT HIM?
>> THERE IS MORE THAT COMEY
SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT.
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
IMMUNITY REQUEST IN THE IG
REPORT IS BECAUSE THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HAS
SCHEDULED A HEARING TO DISCUSS
THE IG REPORT ONCE IT'S MADE
PUBLIC.
THEY HAD SCHEDULED ONE FOR
JUNE 5.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
THEY SCHEDULED THE NEXT ONE FOR
NEXT MONDAY, JUNE 11.
LOOKS LIKE THAT MIGHT NOT HAPPEN
BUT IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN FAIRLY
SOON.
THEY WANTED McCABE TO TESTIFY.
NOW HE IS ASKED FOR IMMUNITY,
AND THERE'S MORE THAN JUST THE
COMEY VERSUS McCABE, I LEAKED
BUT YOU TOLD ME I COULD.
NO, I DIDN'T.
THERE IS MORE THAN THAT.
THERE'S TALK ABOUT, INFORMATION
ABOUT WHEN McCABE TOOK A LONG
TIME TO RECUSE HIMSELF AFTER HIS
WIFE GOT A LOT OF POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS KIND OF LINKED TO
THE CLINTONS.
McCABE WAS INVOLVED IN EVERY
OTHER DECISION IN THIS CLINTON
THING.
IT'S NOT JUST COMEY VERSUS
McCABE.
>> Shannon: ANOTHER NAME IN
THE MIX IS PETER STRZOK.
HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK HE IS
WRINGING HIS HANDS AND WAITING
FOR THE REPORT.
>> HE WAS AN FBI AGENT WORKING
ON THIS CASE AND BECAUSE OF
THESE VERY -- THESE TEXTS HE
SENT TO HIS GIRLFRIEND
DENOUNCING PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE'S
SEEN AS TAINTING THE EFFORTS HE
WAS DOING WHEN HE WAS WORKING
FOR THE FBI.
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE FAIR BUT
HE'S AN INFLAMMATORY NAME WHEN
YOU SEE IN THINGS LIKE THE ONE
CONTROVERSY OF THE DAY, THE FACT
THAT GSA TURNED OVER A LOT OF
INFORMATION FROM THE TRANSITION
TEAM TO MUELLER WITHOUT A
SUBPOENA, WITHOUT GOING BACK TO
THE TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM TO GET
PERMISSION.
STRZOK WAS PART OF THAT.
IT'S AS THOUGH WE ARE IN SUCH A
WORLD OF INVESTIGATION THAT
THERE IS NO ELEMENT THAT DOES
NOT GET CAUGHT UP IN THIS.
>> Shannon: ALSO CONGRESS HAS
BEEN VERY BUSY WITH
INVESTIGATIONS BUT NOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE BUSY, AT LEAST THE
SENATE SIDE, IN AUGUST THANKS TO
SENATE LEADER MITCH MCCONNELL
SAY THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN
SESSION.
HERE'S THE TOP REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT OF THE SENATE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THEY MIGHT BE DOING.
>> WHY DON'T WE GET SOMETHING
DONE ON THE ISSUE THAT NUMEROUS
POLLS SAY IS THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY OF AMERICANS?
HEALTH CARE.
WE DEMOCRATS, OUR ENTIRE CAUCUS,
BELIEVES THIS PREVIOUSLY ON
SCHEDULED SESSION TIME CAN BE
PUT TO GOOD USE.
>> WE NEED TO CONFIRM MORE OF
THE PRESIDENTS TEAM AND JUDICIAL
NOMINEES.
WE NEED TO TAKE UP A REGULAR
APPROPRIATION BILLS.
WE NEED TO TACKLE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES LIKE THE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THE FARM
BILL, DEFENSE BILL.
MANY OTHERS.
>> Shannon: JONAH, BOTH SIDES
HAVE LAID OUT A PRETTY AMBITIOUS
SCHEDULE.
DOES ANY OF THAT GET DONE?
>> THERE ARE -- CONSPIRACY
THEORIES IS TOO STRONG A BOARD
BUT THERE ARE THEORIES THAT WHAT
McCONNELL IS TRYING TO DO IS
PULL BACK DEMOCRATS FROM THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL MAKE THEM BE
STUCK HERE.
THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE WHO SAY
NO, THIS IS REALLY ABOUT PUTTING
A GUN TO THE DEMOCRATS' HEADS SO
HE CAN CRAM MORE JUDGES THROUGH.
I DON'T SEE WHY WE HAVE TO FIT
ONE OF THOSE.
BUT I DON'T THINK THERE'S GOING
TO BE -- THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE
LIKE THE FIRST 100 DAYS OF THE
NEW DEAL COMING OUT IN D.C. IN
AUGUST.
>> Shannon: WE SAW THE
FIRST LADY TODAY.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED THIS:
"THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA HAS BEEN SO
UNFAIR, AND VICIOUS, TO MY WIFE
AND OUR GREAT FIRST LADY,
MELANIA.
DURING HER RECOVERY FROM SURGERY
THEY REPORTED EVERYTHING FROM
NEAR DEATH, TO FACELIFT,
TO LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND ME FOR NEW YORK OR VIRGINIA,
TO ABUSE.
ALL FAKE, SHE IS DOING REALLY
WELL!"
SUSAN, THERE'S BEEN A TON OF
SPECULATION.
TODAY WE SAW HER AND SHE DID
LOOK WELL.
>> A WORD OF MY HUSBAND IS
WATCHING, IF YOU ARE GOING TO
DENY SOMETHING, DO NOT DENY I
HAD A FACE-LIFT.
NOT THE APPROACH I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE.
I AM SORT OF IN THE LEAVE
MELANIA TRUMP ALONE CAMP.
SHE DIDN'T RUN FOR OFFICE.
SHE'S NOT WEIGHING IN ON POLICY.
I THINK IF SHE -- THIS GOT
STARTED BECAUSE SHE WAS KIND OF
OUT OF SIGHT FOR THREE WEEKS BUT
IF SHE WANTS TO STAY OUT OF